you
what I do for a living is I try to make
a difference in the world I realize
that's not very specific that I should
pin it down a bit but I am very
interested in how we make the systems
around us work to produce benefits for
the people in them and the people that
they serve that's always been very
important I work with large companies
some of the most important global giants
in the world but I work with them about
change about transformation about a
positive impact I've always stood for
empowerment of people and I do this
through a combination of ways it's the
words I say the words I put in other
people's mouths because I get quoted
frequently it's through direct advice
doing research and projects for
particular organizations it's through my
students at Harvard Business School and
occasionally at Harvard College the
undergraduates that I influence it's
through my faculty colleagues now I'm
working with faculty from public health
and education law government and
business on a new project where we think
we can deploy leaders at later stages in
their lives to solve key problems of the
world poverty education Public Health
and Environment and so I I get a chance
to work in all of those domains but I
work through helping leaders become
better leaders of major institutions
this is what makes the world go around
its strategy its defining a vision of
mission and but it's not only
implementing what you've already done
it's doing something new and better not
for the sake of being different but for
the sake of improving upon what's been
done before in order to have a bigger
impact on more people there are about
six billion people in the world today
and a large number actually I shouldn't
say six billion people in world i'm not
sure what the number is i recently spoke
to somebody who was participating in
developing the earth charter and he said
well we could then do something for six
billion people of the world and i said
yes but there might be three billion
people of the world who won't care about
the earth yet because they're still
hungry they still need food on the table
every day in a better life for their
families I believe that business
particularly socially responsible
business can be a potent force for
making a difference in all of those
areas and in recent years the businesses
that I work with are companies that are
trying to not only be effective and
innovative themselves in the interests
of shareholders and profits but they are
also trying to make a difference in all
of the countries and communities in
which they operate to do that they have
to be very strategic they need excellent
values-based leaders and they certainly
have to know how to innovate I feel that
the world desperately needs innovation
innovation I that the world desperately
needs innovative solutions to problems
it needs creative thinking I think it's
exciting it's open-ended I think the
21st century has has the the i think
that the 20th century can be the time
when we finally could become one planet
lifting the fortunes of everybody
exploring
galaxies I was very influenced by Star
Trek I really love that idea that there
are other worlds out there to explore it
could also be a century of bloody
conflict and tensions but I want to help
educate leaders who are going to ensure
that their power their resources their
organizations are guided to help make
the world a better place there have been
many efforts to write about strategy
leadership innovation organizational
change this became particularly popular
in the recent era the last 30 years that
we can call the global information age
in the Machine Age the Industrial Age it
was certainly important to innovate and
technological innovations and
breakthroughs have shaped our world from
the automobile to the airplane to air
conditioning to other bells and whistles
of technology but in the global
information age where people can be so
interconnected it became even more
important to seek new models and in fact
a whole set of feisty new
entrepreneurial companies starting with
Apple computer in the late 1970s said
we're going to do things differently and
we're going to democratize technology
Apple's first slogan was bicycles for
the mind and I thought that was a
brilliant way of talking about providing
a new utility for people to communicate
with and so we've known a great deal
about innovation through the years and
we've had successive waves of effort to
research and write about innovation and
there are a few lessons that have been
enduring I was one of the early writers
about this modern wave of innovation in
1983 in a book called the change masters
and much of what i discovered then about
the culture for innovation what
stimulates creativity what steps an
innovator has to go through in order to
get acceptance for an ID
those are all the same after all
innovation is something that is only
good in retrospect after it's worked we
all say we want more innovation but we
don't want crazy ideas we want things
that are proven but before they're
proven it's very hard work not simply to
have the idea to create the invention
but to convince other people to reshape
the context so that there will be
receptivity for the innovation and the
lessons about change and resistance to
change our enduring I'm sure they've
been with us for centuries since the
Greeks the Arabs or the Chinese
inventors in early civilizations they
must have all heard that's impossible
we've tried it before and it hasn't
worked well innovators are up against
the same thing no matter what their era
and today in the 21st century we
continue to rediscover those same
lessons about what produces change
turn around
mean that something has not been working
and has often gone downhill I
distinguish losing streaks and winning
streaks as two very different phenomenon
when things are going down people get
depressed they believe they will always
go down when companies start losing
money when sports teams start losing
games and continue to lose when
nonprofit organizations lose their
funding when countries lose Wars or lose
hope and start heading downhill that's a
losing streak and so to turn that around
toward a winning streak is not just a
matter of solving the immediate problems
financial or it's been the wrong
strategy and model or or there have been
some operational problems there have
been leaks in the buildings there were
disasters that were unexpected it's also
a question of people's attitudes
feelings expectations and morale and so
you not only need a financial strategic
and operational turnaround but also a
psychological and emotional and cultural
turnaround to rebuild confidence
confidence is just an expectation of
success that we can do it we can make it
happen and when leaders lead a
turnaround they have to make people
believe that they can finally make
something happen after so many losses
and that's very very difficult in a
losing streak people give up they lose
hope they go passive and so a great deal
of the work of leadership is not only
solving the immediate problem it is also
lifting people's spirits and giving them
confidence in advance a victory
I certainly believe leaders can be made
I think some people who are
extraordinary our born leaders and they
probably showed it from an early age at
one end of the continuum and I think at
the other end there may be people who
could never be a leader no matter what
we did but I think everybody has in them
the potential to lead and the question
is whether the circumstances evoke that
whether they're given the opportunity
whether they're given chances to
practice mentors who advise them who
guide them who tell them not to make
stupid mistakes whether they're given
the education so that they have the
intellectual ability because remember
leaders are not just emotionally
powerful because people want to follow
them they're also often intellectually
powerful that is they have an important
idea that thinks beyond the current
situation they can set an agenda for
change and so you need a certain
intellectual ability education helps
what I see is that in places whether
it's countries communities or companies
that are that have a positive culture
let me start that again what I see in
communities countries and companies that
have a positive culture that are on a
winning streak that build confidence is
that they also produce more leaders
because they empower more people to take
initiative on actions they see but in
organizations or communities that are
closed bureaucratic hierarchical
top-down one person or a small group
controls everything thereby shutting
everybody else out of the opportunity to
lead and to develop further their skills
in leadership I think Nelson Mandela in
South Africa had to be a natural leader
they're very few people in the world who
could have done what he did I mean 27
years in prison and coming out and
repairing a troubled nation and
forgiving his enemies he's off the
charts when it comes to leadership I
think you probably have to be born
mandela on the other hand i think all of
us could find our inner Mandela that is
reach more deeply into ourselves to pull
out the best parts of ourselves that
help us lead and whether we're
encouraged to do that or not has a great
deal to do with the culture that
surrounds us and the support we get from
our colleagues so yes with encouragement
a positive culture and support from
colleagues more people could become
leaders the most exciting thing going on
in business today is the match between a
company's resources and problems in the
world which both triggers innovation
that the world benefits from and that
the company benefits from I think that's
phenomenal it's not corporate social
responsibility its corporate innovation
but but taking on big problems problems
of clean water in places that don't have
it problems of education and in the
course of doing that companies are
developing products and services and the
world is benefiting that's thrilling I
mean I love to see companies succeed and
make money they need to they can't
sustain themselves without good business
models on the other hand when they can
get business benefits and also help
people advance or improve their lives
that's really thrilling and i love the
amount of creativity and creative
thinking that's going on in some very
big companies that's all so exciting to
me by the way because we've moved
through an era where we thought big big
was bad that big companies were
bureaucratic they were stifling they
were dinosaurs and only the small feisty
entrepreneurial companies could make a
difference in the world that was in part
because of the dot-com era in part
because of now the Google's of the world
however today it's also exciting to
watch big companies become feisty
innovative makers of change I love the
creativity and innovation that goes into
positive and productive change it's
inspiring it's personally fulfilling and
it's a model that stimulates all of us
to aspire to greater things we do not
have to accept the world as it is we can
take the best parts learn how to
preserve them and we can solve the
remaining problems
you